Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions an average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂开采产生了大量的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司携手合作，在迈向净零排放的道路上大步迈进。他们投资于技术和创新，已将每桶石油的平均排放量降低了 22%。他们与政府合作创造和保护就业岗位，并开发了世界上最大的碳捕集与储存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 查看我们的行动计划。
Music Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. 21 year old University of Texas student Mark Kilroy was excited about spring break. 1989 had been a busy year for the pre-med student and he was looking forward to some downtime before taking his upcoming medical college admission test. Mark had made plans with three old high school friends to head to South Padre Island on the southern coastal tip of Texas. A trip he had made for spring break twice before.
音乐 我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您手机应用上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。21 岁的德克萨斯大学学生马克·基尔罗伊对春假充满期待。1989 年对于这位预科医学生来说是忙碌的一年，他一直期待在参加即将到来的医学院入学考试前能有一些放松的时间。马克与三位老高中朋友计划前往德克萨斯州南端南帕德雷岛。他以前曾为春假去过那里两次。
Bordered by the Gulf of Mexico to the east and to the long shallow Laguna Madre to the west, South Padre Island boasts a warm subtropical climate typical of the area. After sustaining severe damage from Hurricane Bula in 1967, the island's town was rebuilt with resorts and condos cropping up along the coastline. A tourism boom in the late 1980s established South Padre Island as a popular vacation destination, especially for young spring breakers. In March 1989 alone, the island's population rose from 1,000 to 250,000 as students from all over the United States arrived for a week of beachside partying. Mark Kilroy and his friend Bradley Moore had been discussing spring break since the beginning of the fall semester. The pair attended different Texas-based universities but maintained their friendship by phoning each other at least twice a week. On Friday, March 10, Bradley picked Mark up from his campus in Austin to begin their journey to South Padre Island. They then collected Bill Huddleston and Brett Martin.
南帕德雷岛东临墨西哥湾，西接漫长而浅的拉古纳马德雷，拥有该地区典型的温暖亚热带气候。在 1967 年遭受飓风布拉的严重破坏后，该岛的小镇进行了重建，海岸线上涌现出度假村和公寓。20 世纪 80 年代末的旅游业繁荣确立了南帕德雷岛作为热门度假胜地的地位，尤其是对年轻的春假狂欢者而言。仅在 1989 年 3 月，随着来自全美各地的学生涌入进行为期一周的海滩派对，该岛的人口就从 1,000 人激增至 250,000 人。马克·基尔罗伊和他的朋友布拉德利·穆尔从秋季学期开始就一直在讨论春假。两人就读于德克萨斯州不同的大学，但每周至少通电话两次以维持友谊。3 月 10 日星期五，布拉德利从奥斯汀的校园接上马克，开始了前往南帕德雷岛的旅程。然后他们去接了比尔·赫德尔斯顿和布雷特·马丁。
All four were longtime friends having played basketball and baseball together in high school before disbanding after graduation. They hadn't seen much of each other since and the trip afforded them a long-awaited catch-up. During the four-hour drive to the island, they discussed their upcoming plans for the summer and reflected on how it would likely be their last time in Texas together. The group checked into the Sheraton Hotels and Resorts around mid-morning on Saturday, March 11. Spring break had only just begun and the hotel was still quiet but staff had removed the furniture in the lobby in preparation for the influx of students. Their first two days were spent at the beach behind their hotel, taking advantage of the free entertainment on offer including concerts, movies and parties. Four days into the break on Tuesday, March 14, Lieutenant George Gavito was on duty at the Brownsville Sheriff's Office in Southern Texas when three young men arrived wanting to speak to somebody about one of their friends.
这四人是多年的老朋友，曾在高中一起打篮球和棒球，毕业后各奔东西。自那以后他们见面的机会不多，这次旅行让他们得到了期待已久的聚叙。在驱车前往该岛的四个小时里，他们讨论了即将到来的夏天计划，并反思这可能是他们最后一次一起在德克萨斯州了。3 月 11 日星期六上午，这群人入住喜来登酒店及度假村。春假才刚刚开始，酒店依然很安静，但工作人员已经移走了大厅里的家具，为涌入的学生做准备。他们头两天是在酒店后面的海滩上度过的，享受着提供的免费娱乐活动，包括音乐会、电影和派对。3 月 14 日星期二，即假期开始的第四天，乔治·加维托中尉正在德克萨斯州南部的布朗斯维尔警长办公室值班，当时有三个年轻人前来，想找人谈谈他们其中一个朋友的事。
Bradley Moore, Bill Huddleston and Brett Martin informed the Lieutenant that Mark Kilroy was missing. On the second night of their vacation, Mark's group ventured to the city of Matamoros in northeastern Mexico. Located in the state of Tama-Lepus on the bank of the Rio Grande River, Matamoros is directly across the border from the city of Brownsville on the southernmost tip of Texas. With a population of over a million people, Matamoros was a hotspot for drug trafficking but was considered a safe destination for travelers. The area offered cheap alcohol and lax drinking laws, drawing America's youth to the festive local bars, nightclubs and restaurants. Moving between Brownsville and Matamoros required crossing over the Rio Grande via the Gateway International Bridge, an official port of entry along the two countries' borders. On Sunday, March 12, 1989, Mark Kilroy and his crew drove to Brownsville where they left their car before walking across the Gateway International Bridge into Mexico. They spent the night socializing at Sergeant Pepper's nightclub until around 2.30am when they returned to Texas and made their way back to South Padre Island.
布拉德利·穆尔、比尔·赫德尔斯顿和布雷特·马丁向中尉报告说马克·基尔罗伊失踪了。在假期的第二晚，马克的小组冒险去了墨西哥东北部的马塔莫罗斯市。马塔莫罗斯位于格兰德河畔的塔毛利帕斯州，位于德克萨斯州最南端布朗斯维尔市的正对岸。马塔莫罗斯人口超过一百万，是毒品走私的热点地区，但被认为是对旅行者安全的目的地。该地区提供廉价的酒精和宽松的饮酒法律，吸引了美国的年轻人前往节日般的当地酒吧、夜总会和餐厅。在布朗斯维尔和马塔莫罗斯之间穿梭需要经由网关国际大桥跨越格兰德河，这是两国边境沿线的一个官方入境口岸。1989 年 3 月 12 日星期日，马克·基尔罗伊和他的同伴开车到布朗斯维尔，把车留下，然后步行穿过网关国际大桥进入墨西哥。他们在佩珀中士夜总会社交到凌晨 2 点 30 分左右，随后返回德克萨斯州并返回南帕德雷岛。
The group decided to venture back to Matamoros the following night of Monday, March 13. The city was a hive of activity, with approximately 15,000 spring breakers traversing the crowded main streets. The four friends wandered down the first thoroughfare after the bridge, the nightclub-lined Avenida Álvaro Obregon. Bill Huddleston described the area. It was like an amusement park but without the rides. It was one big thrill, the energy that was created by thousands and thousands of students. They entered the bar with the shortest line out front, Los Sombreros, then headed to the Hard Rock Cafe where Mark met some girls and separated from his friends. The crowds were dispersing by 2am and Bill suggested to Bradley and Brent that they go back to their hotel.
该小组决定在第二天晚上，即 3 月 13 日星期星期一再次冒险前往马塔莫罗斯。这座城市活动频繁，大约有 15,000 名春假狂欢者穿梭在拥挤的主干道上。四个朋友沿着桥后的第一条大道闲逛，那是林立着夜总会的阿尔瓦罗·奥布雷贡大道。比尔·赫德尔斯顿这样描述该地区：“这就像一个游乐园，只是没有游乐设施。成千上万的学生所产生的能量带来了一场巨大的狂欢。”他们走进了排队最短的酒吧“太阳帽”，然后前往硬石餐厅，在那里马克遇到了一些女孩并与朋友们分开了。到了凌晨 2 点，人群开始散去，比尔建议布拉德利和布雷特回酒店。
The trio exited the bar and spotted Mark talking to a girl he had befriended on South Padre Island days earlier. He rejoined the group as they slowly made their way down the few blocks towards the Gateway International Bridge. The four tried to stay close to one another in a shoulder-to-shoulder formation but inevitably split into pairs as they navigated the thousands of intoxicated students moving aimlessly around the street. Bradley and Brent were ahead with Bill and Mark a few yards behind. When they reached the front of Garcia's, a one-story red and grey brick building that served as a local watering hole and gift shop, Mark stopped to say goodbye to the girl he'd been speaking to as Bill ran off to find somewhere secluded to urinate. When Bill re-emerged, Mark was nowhere to be seen. Assuming he must have continued onwards, Bill reached the bridge where Bradley and Brent were waiting. They called out for Mark but he didn't appear.
三人走出酒吧，发现马克正在和一个几天前在南帕德雷岛结识的女孩聊天。他重新加入了队伍，大家慢慢地沿着几条街向网关国际大桥走去。四人试图并肩保持紧密靠拢，但在数千名在街上漫无目的地移动的醉酒学生中穿行时，不可避免地分成了两组。布拉德利和布雷特在前，比尔和马克在几码后。当他们到达加西亚餐厅（一座用作当地饮水处和礼品店的单层红灰色砖砌建筑）门前时，马克停下来向他一直在交谈的女孩道别，而比尔则跑开去找隐蔽的地方小便。当比尔再次出现时，马克已经不见踪影。比尔以为他一定继续前行了，便来到了布拉德利和布雷特等待的桥边。他们大声呼唤马克，但他没有出现。
They were immediately concerned. Mark wasn't the type to abandon the group or go elsewhere without telling them. Thinking Mark may have already crossed the bridge, his friends returned to Brownsville but he wasn't waiting by their car as anticipated. After waiting several minutes, they headed back into Matamoros to search for him. They scoured the nightclubs and bars until 4.30am by which point the streets were mostly empty but they couldn't find Mark anywhere. The trio drove back to South Padre Island hoping he had returned to their hotel on his own but there was no sign of him there either. The group considered the possibility that Mark had been thrown in jail and returned to Matamoros the following day to check the local police stations but to now avail. Officers expressed little concern as visiting students were often reported missing while partying in town but typically reappeared unharmed a few days later with nothing more than a hangover. Certain this wasn't the case with Mark, his friends went back to Brownsville to speak with police there.
他们立刻感到担忧。马克不是那种会抛弃团队或在不打招呼的情况下独自离开的人。朋友们以为马克可能已经过桥了，便返回布朗斯维尔，但他并没有像预期那样在车旁等待。等待了几分钟后，他们又返回马塔莫罗斯寻找他。他们搜寻了夜总会和酒吧直到凌晨 4 点半，此时街道大多空无一人，但他们到处都找不到马克。三人开车回到南帕德雷岛，希望他已经独自回到了酒店，但在那里也没有他的踪迹。这群人考虑了马克被关进监狱的可能性，并在第二天返回马塔莫罗斯检查当地的警察局，但无济于事。警官们对此并不太在意，因为来访的学生在镇上狂欢时经常被报失踪，但通常几天宿醉过后就会无恙地重新出现。确信马克并非如此，他的朋友们回到布朗斯维尔与那里的警察交谈。
Lieutenant George Gavito suggested that Mark may have left with the girl he had spent the night talking to but his friends insisted he was not that type of person and would never leave without telling them his plans. Lieutenant Gavito filed a missing persons report and Bill, Brent and Bradley visited the US consulate while intermittently returning to their hotel to check if Mark had returned. When Mark hadn't shown up by 11pm on Tuesday night they contacted his parents, James and Helen. The Kilroy family were close knit with Mark the eldest of two sons. Bill Huddleston recalled feeling a tremendous sense of loss breaking the news as the reality of the situation sunk in. Mark's unexplained disappearance was of great concern to his parents as their clean cut firstborn was not a big partier nor was he a loo for careless but a leader who always gave 110%. He excelled both academically and athletically as a former boy scout, honours student and student council member who was skilled at basketball, baseball and golf. Following high school, Mark earned a basketball scholarship that he put aside to focus on his goal to become a general practice doctor.
乔治·加维托中尉暗示马克可能是和那个共度一晚的女孩一起离开的，但他的朋友们坚称他不是那种人，绝不会在没有告知计划的情况下离开。加维托中尉提交了一份失踪人口报告，比尔、布雷特和布拉德利访问了美国领事馆，同时断断续续地返回酒店检查马克是否已经回来。到了周二晚上 11 点马克仍未露面，他们联系了他的父母詹姆斯和海伦。基尔罗伊一家关系紧密，马克是两个儿子中的老大。比尔·赫德尔斯顿回忆说，当现实情况袭来时，宣布这一消息让他感到巨大的失落感。马克莫名其妙的失踪让他的父母非常担忧，因为他们品学兼优的长子并不是一个爱狂欢的人，也不是一个粗心大意的人，而是一个总是付出 110% 努力的领袖。他曾在学业和体育上表现出色，曾是童子军、荣誉学生和学生会成员，擅长篮球、棒球和高尔夫。高中毕业后，马克获得了一项篮球奖学金，但他将其搁置一边，专注于成为一名全科医生的目标。
His former high school basketball coach Terry Ray stated, You always knew whatever he was doing out there, if it was Mark, it would be okay. Mark's uncle worked at the US Custom Service in Los Angeles and to use his connections to draw more attention to his nephew's disappearance. A task force to front the search was established in Brownsville despite American police having no jurisdiction to investigate in Mexico. Mexican police attempted to shift blame by alleging Mark had disappeared in Texas even though his friends firmly denied these claims. Realising the incident made discourage spring breakers from returning to Matamoros, government officials pressured local police to act. Within 48 hours of Mark's disappearance, the Mexican federal and state judicial police joined the US task force as investigators on both sides of the border checked hotels, hospitals, jails and morgues. After three days of unsuccessful searching, Mark's friends were asked to re-enact the events leading to his disappearance.
他以前的高中篮球队教练特里·雷说：“你总是知道他在外面做任何事，只要是马克，就一定会没事的。”马克的叔叔在洛杉矶的美国海关服务局工作，利用自己的人脉为他侄子的失踪吸引更多关注。尽管美国警方没有在墨西哥调查的管辖权，但在布朗斯维尔还是成立了一个负责搜救的工作组。墨西哥警方试图通过声称马克在德克萨斯州失踪来转移责任，尽管他的朋友们坚决否认这些说法。意识到这起事件可能会阻碍春假狂欢者重返马塔莫罗斯，政府官员向当地警方施压要求其采取行动。在马克失踪后的小时内，墨西哥联邦和州司法警察加入了美国工作组，作为双方边境的调查人员检查了酒店、医院、监狱和停尸房。经过三天徒劳的搜寻后，马克的朋友们被要求重新演绎导致他失踪的经过。
As the last one to have seen Mark, Bill Huddleston was placed under hypnosis to see if his subconscious memory had retained any key details. He described walking past Garcia's and sighting a Hispanic male with a cut on his cheek and wearing a blue plaid shirt. The stranger motioned to Mark in English and he stopped to talk. Later, Bill told the Washington Post newspaper that he heard the man ask, Hey, don't I know you from somewhere? Bill clarified, it was just a glimpse. I don't even know if Mark answered him. Within days, texts and newspapers were reporting on the baffling case. The Kilroy family offered a $5,000 reward for information with James and Helen voicing concerns that their son may have been abducted.
作为最后一个见到马克的人，比尔·赫德尔斯顿接受了催眠，以查看他的潜意识记忆是否保留了任何关键细节。他描述说自己走过加西亚餐厅时，看到了一名脸上有伤口、身穿蓝色格子衬衫的西班牙裔男子。那个陌生人用英语向马克示意，马克停下来与他交谈。后来，比尔告诉《华盛顿邮报》报社，他听到那个人问：“嘿，我是不是在哪里见过你？”比尔澄清说：“那只是一瞥。我甚至不知道马克有没有回答他。”几天之内，文字和报纸都在报道这个令人困惑的案件。基尔罗伊一家悬赏 5,000 美元征集线索，詹姆斯和海伦对他们的儿子可能被绑架表示担忧。
Helen explained, I'm extremely worried about him because he's pretty responsible. Being the person that he is, he would have contacted us or his friends. Mark was of legal drinking age and had joined his friends in consuming alcohol, but he had no interest in drugs. A devout Catholic, he took his faith seriously, often carrying a Bible that he'd read between studying. Although outgoing and fun, he was cautious and safe. Brent Martin, quote, I've known the guy ever since kindergarten. He wouldn't go off and just not call us. He's really smart. That's why this whole thing is so weird. Because as smart as he is, he would figure out a way to get in touch with us.
海伦解释道：“我非常担心他，因为他相当负责任。以他的为人，他会联系我们或他的朋友。”马克已达到法定饮酒年龄，并和朋友们一起饮酒，但他对毒品毫无兴趣。作为一名虔诚的天主教徒，他非常重视自己的信仰，经常随身携带一本在学习间隙阅读的圣经。虽然外向且有趣，但他谨慎且安全。布雷特·马丁说：“我从幼儿园就认识这家伙了。他绝不会就这样走开而不给我们打电话。他非常聪明。这就是为什么整件事这么诡异，因为以他的聪明才智，他会想办法和我们取得联系。”
Police were starting to suspect Mark may have been attacked, robbed or fallen victim to drug-related violence and checked Matamoros' shanty towns and colonies known for their high crime rates. Bill Huddleston's hypnosis-induced memories led some to theorize Mark had been murdered as part of a botched kidnapping for ransom plot. As many tourists were still coming and going from the city, authorities were urged to solve the case quickly to ensure no one else felt victim to a similar fate. James Kilroy arrived in Brownsville, spending long hours each day speaking with investigators, developing strong connections with local reporters and handing out missing person flyers in South Padre and Matamoros, assisted by volunteers. Helen Kilroy remained by their home phone in nearby Santa Fe in case it rang with any news. Convinced that her son was being held against his will, she felt a haunting sense that he was being harmed every time she read her Bible. Quote, I've really felt strongly that somehow he's being hurt right now. I kept reading that nothing is impossible with God.
警方开始怀疑马克可能遭到袭击、抢劫或沦为贩毒暴力活动的受害者，并对马塔莫罗斯以高犯罪率闻名的贫民窟和社区进行了排查。比尔·赫德尔斯顿在催眠状态下唤醒的记忆让一些人推测，马克是被作为一场失败的勒索绑架案的一部分而被谋杀的。由于仍有许多游客进出该市，当局被敦促迅速破案，以确保没有其他人沦为类似命运的受害者。詹姆斯·基尔罗伊抵达布朗斯维尔，每天花很长时间与调查人员交谈，与当地记者建立牢固的联系，并在志愿者协助下在南帕德雷和马塔莫罗斯分发失踪人员传单。海伦·基尔罗伊则守在附近圣达菲的家中电话旁，以防有任何消息打进来。坚信儿子违背意愿被扣留的她，每次读圣经时都有一种挥之不去的阴森感，觉得儿子正在遭受伤害。她说：“我真的强烈地感觉到，此时此刻他正以某种方式受到伤害。我一直在读‘在神没有难成的事’。”
I feel like Mark's going to come back to us. Whoever has him, I just don't want them to be so frightened that they would fatally hurt Mark. We don't have any anger toward that person. We just want Mark back. With everyone praying like this, I don't see how the Lord can refuse us. By Saturday, March 18, 80 officers were involved in the search. A police helicopter scanned the banks of the Rio Grande River as officers in four-wheel drives combed the brush-covered countryside on both sides of the border. 15 criminals known to operate in the area were questioned, including pickpockets and drug dealers. Possible links to other crimes committed over the spring break period were examined, including the murder of a Mexican truck driver, the abduction and sexual assault of a young American woman, and the violent robbery of another student, all of which occurred within five blocks of the Gateway International Bridge. In Brownsville, fundraisers increased the reward pool to $15,000, which was a significant amount in Matamoros, where daily wages averaged around $2 to $3.
“我觉得马克会回到我们身边。无论谁抓了他，我只希望他们不要害怕到致命地伤害马克。我们对那个人没有任何愤怒。我们只想要马克回来。大家都这样祈祷，我看不出主怎么能拒绝我们。”截至 3 月 18 日星期六，已有 80 名警察参与搜救。一架警用直升机在格兰德河沿岸巡视，四驱车上的警官们则在边境两侧灌木丛生的乡村中梳理。15 名已知在该地区活动的罪犯受到了讯问，包括扒手和毒贩。针对春假期间发生的其他犯罪行为的潜在联系也受到了审查，包括一名墨西哥卡车司机的谋杀、一名年轻美国女性的绑架和性侵犯，以及对另一名学生的暴力抢劫，所有这些都发生在网关国际大桥五个街区之内。在布朗斯维尔，筹款活动将悬赏金池增加到 15,000 美元，这在马塔莫罗斯是一笔巨款，那里的日薪平均在 2 到 3 美元左右。
But despite the reward and investigative efforts, leads were already drying up. Almost two weeks after Mark vanished, his disappearance was featured in a 10-minute segment of Fox Television's America's Most Wanted that was broadcast in the U.S. and Mexico, generating a total of 2,000 calls from the public. A Mexican woman called to implicate her boyfriend, a Matamoros police officer who spoke of arresting a drunk American, fitting Mark's description. After a failed attempt to extort money from the American, the officer shot him. As police corruption was a serious problem in Mexico, investigators honed in on an officer with ties to the criminal underworld, but he was ultimately ruled out. Calls placed Mark at various Mexican beaches, while some saw him in the company of a woman, and others claimed he was restrained. Investigators noticed that references to occult rituals and sacrifices kept cropping up, including a letter delivered to police that was covered in scribblings of pentagrams and other symbols. It featured a single sentence in Spanish that translated to, Mark was not the first.
但尽管有悬赏和调查努力，线索已经开始枯竭。在马克失踪近两周后，他的失踪案被搬上了福克斯电视台《全美通缉令》节目的一段 10 分钟片段，在美国和墨西哥播出，共引发了公众的 2,000 通电话。一名墨西哥妇女打电话来牵连她的男友，后者是马塔莫罗斯的一名警察，曾谈到逮捕了一名符合马克特征的醉酒美国人。在向美国人勒索金钱未遂后，这名警察开枪打死了他。由于警察腐败是墨西哥的一个严重问题，调查人员将目标锁定在与犯罪黑社会有联系的一名警察身上，但他最终被排除。打来的电话将马克安置在各个墨西哥海滩，一些人看到他和一个女人在一起，还有人声称他被拘禁了。调查人员注意到，关于神秘仪式和献祭的说法不断出现，包括一封交到警察局的信，上面涂满了五角星和其他符号。信中有一句西班牙语翻译过来就是：“马克不是第一个。”
Helen Kilroy received a collect call from a man identifying himself as Danny, claiming to have seen Mark at a drug dealer's house in the city of Houston, Texas. Danny demanded $10,000 for all the information he knew. Helen agreed and arranged to meet him outside a gas station at 5pm the following day. Covert police officers overseeing the exchange noted several suspicious people milling around, but Danny did not approach. Another call came later that night, this time from a man calling himself Junior, who had noticed the police presence at the drop site. A second exchange was arranged for the next day at a nearby cemetery. Junior threatened to cut off Mark's fingers and send them to Helen if the police were notified this time. At 5pm on April 6, Helen went to the cemetery as arranged, once again under covert surveillance, but no one came forward to collect the ransom.
海伦·基尔罗伊接到一个自称丹尼的男人的对方付费电话，对方声称在德克萨斯州休斯顿市的一个毒贩家里看到了马克。丹尼索要 10,000 美元作为他所知道的所有信息的报酬。海伦同意了，并安排第二天下午 5 点在一家加油站外与他见面。监督这笔交易的便衣警察注意到周围有几个可疑的人闲逛，但丹尼并没有走近。那天晚些时候又打来了一个电话，这次是一个自称小尤宁的男人，他注意到了交易地点的警察。第二次交换安排在第二天附近的墓地进行。小尤宁威胁说，如果这次报警，他会切断马克的指头并寄给海伦。4 月 6 日下午 5 点，海伦按排好的去了墓地，再次处于秘密监视之下，但没有人出面收取赎金。
Investigators traced the calls to phones inside the Galveston County Jail in Texas. They were positioned in the souls of two inmates, Robert Miller and Wilton Smith, and were only supposed to be used to contact family and attorneys. Both men were serving time for burglary, and Miller had previously been charged with extortion after attempting to scam money from the family of missing teenager Shelly Sykes, who had disappeared three years earlier. Assured by government officials that efforts to find his son would persist, James Kilroy returned home. Mayor Jack Long encouraged Santa Fe residents to wear yellow ribbons in support of the Kilroy family, with benefits, auctions, garage sales and bake sales held to increase the reward pool. US customs agent Oren Neck told the media, This is definitely one of the most difficult cases I've ever dealt with. There appears to be no motive, no nothing. On Saturday, April 1, police in Matamoros set up a routine traffic stop on Mexican Federal Highway 2 to check passing cars but narcotics.
调查人员将这些电话追溯到德克萨斯州加尔维斯顿县监狱内的电话。它们原本只被放置在两名囚犯罗伯特·米勒和威尔顿·Smith的牢房里，且只应该用于联系家人和律师。这两名男子都在因入室盗窃服刑，米勒此前曾因试图向三年前失踪的失踪青少年雪莉·赛克斯的家人诈骗钱财而被指控敲诈勒索。在政府官员向其保证搜寻其儿子的努力将继续下去后，詹姆斯·基尔罗伊回到了家中。市长杰克·朗鼓励圣达菲居民佩戴黄丝带以支持基尔罗伊一家，并举办了慈善义演、拍卖、车库售卖和烘焙义卖来增加悬赏金额。美国海关特工奥伦·内克对媒体表示：“这绝对是我处理过的最困难的案件之一。似乎没有任何动机，什么都没有。”4 月 1 日星期六，马塔莫罗斯警方在墨西哥 2 号联邦公路设立了例行交通检查站，以检查过往车辆是否有毒品。
In the late afternoon, a red pickup truck traveling from Texas sped through the checkpoint, with the young, dark-haired driver ignoring the signs and armed officers alerting vehicles to pull over. One of the officers recognized the pickup's driver as a regular at bars downtown, 20-year-old Seraphine Hernandez Rivera, described as a loud-mouthed punk. The Hernandez family had been in the drug trade for over a decade and had ties to powerful dealers, but were only considered mid-level smugglers themselves. Seraphine was a US citizen and lived in Brownsville, where his father ran the American side of their operations, including the transportation of a thousand pounds of marijuana from Mexico each week. He was close to his Matamoros-based uncle, 22-year-old Elio Hernandez Rivera, the organization's leader. Undercover officers in an unmarked police vehicle tailed Seraphine 20 miles west, arriving at a small cattle ranch titled Rancho Santa Helena. They pulled off the main road and kept a watch from a distance. When Seraphine left the property 30 minutes later, they drove down the half-mile-long dirt driveway and pulled up to a large, corrugated steel warehouse with a red-brown wooden shack to its left, pens for livestock, and a number of new and high-end cars and trucks parked out the front.
傍晚时分，一辆从德克萨斯州开来的红色皮卡加速冲过检查站，年轻、黑发的司机无视标志和示意车辆靠边停车的武装警察。其中一名警官认出这辆皮卡的司机是市中心酒吧的常客，20 岁的塞拉芬·埃尔南德斯·里维拉，被描述为一个大嘴巴的恶棍。埃尔南德斯家族涉足毒品交易已有十多年，与强大的贩毒集团有联系，但他们自己只被视为中层走私犯。塞拉芬是美国公民，住在布朗斯维尔，他的父亲在那里负责他们行动的美国一侧，包括每周从墨西哥运输一千磅大马力大麻。他与他在马塔莫罗斯的叔叔、22 岁的埃利奥·埃尔南德斯·里维拉关系密切，后者是该组织的头目。一辆无标志警车中的便衣警察尾随塞拉芬向西行驶了 20 英里，抵达了一座名为圣海伦娜牧场的小型养牛场。他们驶离主干道并在远处进行监视。30 分钟后塞拉芬离开该物业时，他们沿着半英里长的泥土车道开车驶入，停在了一个大型波纹钢仓库前，仓库左侧有一个红褐色木屋、牲口围栏，前方停着许多崭新且高端的汽车和卡车。
A man approached and introduced himself as Domingo, the ranch's caretaker. The officers pretended they were lost and in need of directions. As one spoke with Domingo, another got out and examined a blue Chevrolet Suburban SUV that was parked nearby. It was fitted with a car phone, which was a luxury feature in 1989, and contained traces of marijuana. There was also a cement statue in the vehicle with an evil-looking pointed head and facial features made of seashells. Sensing the caretaker was becoming nervous, the officers left the scene. Although they had been under the impression that Hernandez family's drug-smuggling network was on the wane, the expensive vehicles at the ranch led police to believe they were back in business. The property was put under surveillance and agents were sent out to determine the group's activities, size, and connections.
一名男子走过来，自我介绍说是多明戈，牧场的看守人。警官们假装迷路了需要指路。当一人与多明戈交谈时，另一人下车检查了停在附近的一辆蓝色雪佛兰萨博班 SUV。它配备了车载电话，这在 1989 年是奢侈功能，车内还含有大麻痕迹。车里还有一尊水泥雕像，有着邪恶的尖头和用贝壳做成的面部特征。感觉到看守人变得紧张，警察离开了现场。尽管他们原本以为埃尔南德斯家族的走私网络正在衰落，但牧场里的昂贵车辆让警察相信他们卷土重来。该物业被置于监视之下，特工被派去确定该团伙的活动、规模和关系。
Meanwhile, the statue in the blue Chevrolet was identified as a legua, a guard from Palo, an Afro-Cuban religion devoted to earthly powers and the worship of spirits. A legua was considered a trickster and a deity of the roads. Worshipers believed making offerings to him would protect them on their travels. Just over a week later on Sunday, April 9, police stormed Rancho Santa Elena and found 64 pounds of marijuana and several firearms. Seraphine, his uncle Elio, and two other men, David, Serna, Valdez, and Sergio Martinez Salinas, were placed under arrest for drug trafficking. The four men were interrogated into the early hours, but each maintained relaxed demeanors and refused to answer questions. The ranch's caretaker, Domingo Bustamante, arrived for work that morning unaware that his employers had been arrested. When questioned by police, Domingo said roughly three to four weeks prior, a tall blonde-haired young man was in the back of the blue Chevrolet suburban, bound and blindfolded. The captive spoke English, which Domingo couldn't understand as he only spoke Spanish.
与此同时，蓝色雪佛兰里的雕像被确认为“莱瓜”，一种来自帕罗（一个崇拜世俗权力和精神的非裔古巴宗教）的守护神。莱瓜被认为是一个恶作剧者和道路之神。崇拜者相信向他献祭会保护他们的旅行。仅仅一周多后的 4 月 9 日星期日，警察突袭了圣海伦娜牧场，发现了 64 磅大麻和几支枪械。塞拉芬、他的叔叔埃利奥以及另外两名男子大卫·塞尔纳·瓦尔德斯和塞尔吉奥·马丁内斯·萨利纳斯因涉嫌贩毒被捕。这四名男子被审讯至凌晨，但每个人都保持着放松的姿态并拒绝回答问题。牧场看守人多明戈·布斯塔曼特那天早上来上班时，并不知道他的雇主已经被捕。当被警方讯问时，多明戈说大约三四周前，一个高个子金发年轻男子被绑住双眼并绑在蓝色雪佛兰萨博班的后座上。俘虏说英语，多明戈听不懂，因为他只会说西班牙语。
He was kept in the vehicle overnight, and feeling sorry for him, Domingo fed him and gave him water. The bosses took the prisoner away in the morning, and Domingo didn't know what happened to him after that. When shown a photo of Mark Kilroy, Domingo stated, Yes, that's him. Following this revelation, police intensified their interrogations of the four men in custody until Seraphine finally cracked. He explained that the group belonged to a religious sect led by a Cuban-American sorcerer named Adolfo de Jesús Constanzo, referred to as their godfather. Over the previous months, Constanzo had ordered his followers to conduct several sacrificial rituals, believing they would bring strength, abundance, immunity from injury, and protection from law enforcement. In a calm and deadpan manner, Seraphine revealed that Mark Kilroy had been killed as part of these rituals.
他被关在车里过夜，多明戈因为同情他而给他喂了水和食物。老板们在早上把囚犯带走了，多明戈不知道他之后发生了什么。当被出示马克·基尔罗伊的照片时，多明戈说：“是的，就是他。”这一消息曝光后，警方加强了对被拘留四人的审讯，直到塞拉芬终于崩溃。他解释说，该团伙属于一个由古巴裔美国巫师阿道夫·德赫苏斯·孔斯坦佐（被称为他们的教父）领导的宗教教派。在过去的几个月里，孔斯坦佐下令他的信徒进行多项献祭仪式，相信这会带来力量、财富、免受伤害以及逃避执法的保护。塞拉芬以冷静而面无表情的方式透露，马克·基尔罗伊作为这些仪式的一部分被杀害了。
Quote, It was our religion. Our voodoo. The following day of Tuesday, April 11, investigators from Mexico and the United States descended on Rancho Santa Elena. They escorted Seraphine to the property, whose ongoing, relaxed demeanor irked Mexican officers, who beat him with their clubs and hands, believing he lacked remorse or fear of consequences. Investigators approached the wooden shack alongside the warehouse and were met with the stench of death. The Mexican police expressed hesitancy to go inside due to their fear of witchcraft. Superstition and belief in the occult were fairly widespread in Mexico, with people from all backgrounds believing in witches, shamans, and sorcerers, as well as negative auras, curses, and spells.
“这是我们的宗教。我们的伏都教。”第二天，即 4 月 11 日星期二，来自墨西哥和美国的调查人员涌向圣海伦娜牧场。他们护送塞拉芬前往该物业，他持续放松的举止激怒了墨西哥警官，他们用警棍和双手殴打他，认为他缺乏悔意或对后果的恐惧。调查人员走近仓库旁边的木屋，迎面扑来死亡的恶臭。由于对巫术的恐惧，墨西哥警察表现出不愿进去的犹豫。迷信和对神秘事物的信仰在墨西哥相当普遍，各阶层的人都相信女巫、萨满和巫师，以及消极的光环、诅咒和咒语。
Herbs, potions, charms, and magical amulets were sold in markets, and rituals were performed to cure or repel a variety of afflictions and dilemmas. Seraphine was taken into the shack, where officers found two lit candles on the floor, indicating that someone had been inside as recently as that morning. Near the candles, four kettles contained a dead rooster, a goat's head, a turtle, coins, twigs, and an alegua statue. The floor was littered with tequila bottles, coins, half-smoked cigars, and chili peppers. Dried blood was spattered everywhere, and two bloody wires hung from a beam above, which Seraphine explained were used to hold people by their wrists while their blood was drained. An iron cauldron sat in the centre of the room, later identified as an nganga, a religious receptacle central to the Paolo religion, believed to be inhabited by a spirit of the dead who acts as a guide for all ceremonies performed with the nganga. The rancho Santa Elena nganga was filled with what was described as a soup, made from sticks, a goat's head, chicken feet, bones, a turtle, herbs, a horseshoe, coins, blood, strands of hair, and what appeared to be human remains. Seraphine said Mark Kilroy's brains were in the pot.
草药、魔药、护身符和魔法护符在市场上出售，并举行仪式以治愈或驱除各种痛苦和困境。塞拉芬被带进木屋，警官们在那里发现地板上有两支点燃的蜡烛，表明当天早上曾有人在里面。在蜡烛附近，四个大锅里装着一只死公鸡、一个山羊头、一只乌龟、硬币、树枝和一个莱瓜雕像。地板上散落着龙舌兰酒瓶、硬币、抽了一半的雪茄和辣椒。干涸的血迹到处都是，上面挂着两条带血的电线，塞拉芬解释说，这些电线用于在手腕放血时固定人们。房间中央摆着一口铁质大锅，后来被确认是一个“恩甘加”，这是帕罗宗教的核心宗教容器，被认为是由一个死者的灵魂居住的，担任所有用恩甘加进行的仪式的向导。圣海伦娜的恩甘加里面装满了被称为汤的东西，由树枝、山羊头、鸡爪、骨头、乌龟、草药、马蹄铁、硬币、血液、头发丝以及看起来像人类遗骸的东西制成。塞拉芬说马克的脑子就在罐子里。
The Mexican investigators forced him to drag it outside, and to then immediately conduct a ceremony to drive away the evil spirits, firing their machine guns into the air before rushing into the shack to destroy its contents, dousing everything in holy water. American investigators were stunned by the actions of their Mexican counterparts, and their lack of concern for maintaining the integrity of the crime scene or photographing it before its destruction, but were reluctant to intervene. After the shack's contents had been destroyed, the police asked Seraphine where Mark was buried. He gestured to a spot in one of the livestock pens and said, over there, in the corner. Protruding two to three feet out of the dirt was a long piece of wire, which Seraphine claimed was attached to Mark's spinal cord, so that once his body had decomposed, they would be able to pull it out and wear it as a necklace. Seraphine was handed a shovel and forced to dig up Mark's remains himself. As it worked, he remarked, I don't know why they're making such a big deal of this one here. There's another guy buried over there, and another guy buried over there. When asked to clarify this statement, Seraphine responded, oh yeah, we have other people buried out here. The Mexican migraine pain two ways. Introducing new Advil Plus Acetaminophen. It combines two of the most trusted pain fighting ingredients into one convenient tablet.
墨西哥调查人员强迫他把它拖到外面，然后立即举行仪式以驱除恶鬼，向空中开机枪，然后冲进木屋摧毁里面的东西，把所有东西都浇上圣水。美国调查人员对墨西哥同行的行为感到震惊，他们不关心保持犯罪现场的完整性或在破坏前对其进行拍照，但又不愿意进行干预。木屋内的东西被毁后，警察问塞拉芬马克被埋在哪里。他指着其中一个牲口围栏里的一个地方说：“在那边，角落里。”泥土中伸出两三英尺长的一段铁丝，塞拉芬声称这根铁丝连着马克的脊髓，这样一旦他的尸体分解，他们就可以把它抽出来做成项链戴上。塞拉芬被塞给一把铲子，被迫自己去挖出马克的遗体。当他干活时，他评论道：“我不知道他们为什么要把这个搞得这么大惊小怪。那边还埋着另一个家伙，那边还埋着另一个家伙。”当被要求澄清这一陈述时，塞拉芬回答说：“哦，是的，我们这里还埋着其他人。”墨西哥偏头痛有两种痛法。隆重推出全新 Advil Plus 乙酰氨基酚。它将两种最值得信赖的止痛成分结合到一片便捷的药片中。
Ibuprofen targets pain at the source, and Acetaminophen blocks pain signals, providing fast, effective pain relief for up to eight hours. Conquer headaches fast with the dual action pain fighting relief of new Advil Plus Acetaminophen, now available across Canada. Mark Kilroy's mouth had been taped shut, and there was a gaping wound at the rear of his skull, which had been emptied of brain matter. His legs had been severed at the knees. Seraphine explained this was to make burial easier. Investigators noticed other lumps of dirt throughout the pens, and soon realized they were standing in the midst of a killing field. The four suspects were forced to dig up the remaining bodies at gunpoint, with officers telling them, you'll do it with your hands if you have to. A press conference was held in Brownsville, where County Sheriff Alex Perez explained, it was horrible, it was like a human slaughterhouse. Lieutenant George Gavito added, I've been an investigator for 15 years, and it's one of the worst things I've ever seen.
布洛芬针对源头止痛，乙酰氨基酚则阻断疼痛信号，提供长达八小时的快速、有效止痛。使用全新 Advil Plus 乙酰氨基酚的双重止痛缓解功能快速战胜头痛，现已在全加拿大上市。马克·基尔罗伊的嘴被胶带封住，头骨后部有一个巨大的伤口，里面的脑浆已经被掏空。他的腿在膝盖处被切断。塞拉芬解释说，这是为了使埋葬更容易。调查人员注意到围栏里还有其他泥土块，很快意识到他们正站在一个杀戮场的中心。四个嫌疑人在枪口下被迫挖出剩下的尸体，警察对他们说：“哪怕用手你们也得把它挖出来。”布朗斯维尔举行了一场新闻发布会，县治安官亚历克斯·佩雷斯解释说：“太可怕了，就像一个人肉屠宰场。”乔治·加维托中尉补充说：“我当了 15 年调查员，这是我见过最糟糕的事情之一。”
In total, seven victims were uncovered in the pen, and six more throughout the property. All were male and had been severely mutilated. Several had been skinned, and one was charred. A second farm owned by the Hernandez family called Rancho Los Leones, located two miles south, was also searched, resulting in the discovery of two more bodies. Within 48 hours of news breaking about the mass grave, all the hotel rooms and rental cars in the Rio Grande Valley were booked out, as reporters from across the world flocked to cover the story. Journalists described to those involved as satanic drug smugglers and cannibals, reporting that the cauldron in the shack was used to prepare brains, hearts, and other organs for consumption. On Wednesday, April 12, the four accused, Seraphine Hernandez-Garcia, Elio Hernandez-Rivera, David Cerno Valdez, and Sergio Martinez-Selinas, were paraded across a balcony at the Mexican Federal Judicial Police headquarters in Matamoros. The informal press conference turned into a raucous affair, as the men fielded questions from the hundreds of international reporters gathered below. Elio explained they acted because of their religion, describing himself as his cult's ordained executioner priest.
总共有七名受害者在围栏中被发现，整个物业还有另外六名。所有人都是男性，并且遭受了严重肢解。几人被剥皮，一人被烧焦。埃尔南德斯家族拥有的第二座名为圣莱昂内斯牧场的农场位于南方两英里处，也遭到了搜查，结果发现了另外两具尸体。在关于乱葬岗的新闻爆发出的小时内，格兰德河谷的所有酒店房间和租车都被预订一空，来自世界各地的记者蜂拥而至报道这个故事。记者向有关人员描述他们为邪教贩毒集团和食人族，并报道说木屋里的大锅用于准备供食用的脑子、心脏和其他器官。4 月 12 日星期三，四个被告塞拉芬·埃尔南德斯-加西亚、埃利奥·埃尔南德斯-里维拉、大卫·塞尔诺·瓦尔德斯和塞尔吉奥·马丁内斯-塞利纳斯被游行穿过墨西哥联邦司法警察总部在马塔莫罗斯的阳台。这场非正式的新闻发布会变成了一场喧闹的事件，这些男子回答了下面聚集的数百名国际记者的提问。埃利奥解释说他们的行为是出于他们的宗教信仰，并将自己描述为邪教的受命处决牧师。
A police officer pulled down Elio's shirt, revealing carvings across his arms, chest, and back, which Elio said represented his license to kill. The perpetrators sincerely believed their rituals had made them impervious to the police, with Seraphine challenging an officer to shoot him then and there. Go ahead, your bullets will just bounce off. Arrest warrants were issued for other alleged cult members, including its ringleader, 26-year-old Adolfo de Jesús Constanzo. A paper trail revealed that the morning after Seraphine and his co-accused were taken into custody, Constanzo and three of his followers boarded a flight from Texas to Mexico City, but their current whereabouts were unknown. Constanzo was born and raised in Miami by his Cuban mother, Dalia. Throughout his childhood, Constanzo travelled with his mother to Haiti, where he'd learned about and developed an interest in voodoo. By age 14, he apprenticed a local practitioner of Mayambe, a branch of the Paolo religion, considered to be the world's most powerful and feared form of black magic. Constanzo's neighbours in Miami, who fell foul of the family, started finding headless goats and chickens on their doorsteps, believed to have been left by Dalia, who they suspected to be a witch.
一名警察拉下埃利奥的衬衫，露出了他手臂、胸部和背部的雕刻，埃利奥说这些雕刻代表了他的杀人执照。凶手们真诚地相信他们的仪式使他们刀枪不入，塞拉芬甚至向一名警察挑战当场枪杀他：“来吧，你的子弹只会弹开。”当局对其他所谓的邪教成员发出了逮捕令，包括其头目、26 岁的阿道夫·德赫苏斯·孔斯坦佐。纸质记录显示，在塞拉芬和他的同案被告被拘留的第二天早上，孔斯坦佐和他的三名信徒登上了从德克萨斯州飞往墨西哥城的航班，但他们目前的下落不明。孔斯坦佐在迈阿密由他的古巴母亲达莉亚抚养长大。在他的整个童年时期，孔斯坦佐随母亲前往海地，在那里他了解并培养了对伏都教的兴趣。14 岁时，他师从一名本地的 Mayambe（帕罗宗教的一个分支，被认为是世界上最强大和最令人恐惧的黑魔法形式）实践者。孔斯坦佐在迈阿密的邻居们由于得罪了这家人的利益，开始在门廊上发现无头山羊和鸡，据信这是达莉亚留下的，他们怀疑她是一个女巫。
Constanzo eventually relocated to Mexico City, where he pursued modelling work while supporting himself financially by reading tarot cards. He amassed followers from all walks of life, several of whom became his lovers. By the time he was in his early 20s, Constanzo had established himself as a powerful godfather, performing spells for people down on their luck. His customers included physicians, politicians, models, film stars and police officers. His spells often required animal sacrifices, ranging from roosters, goats and snakes to zebras and lion cubs. The latter cost him upwards of $3,000. He even raided a graveyard to obtain human bones to use in his potions. Constanzo had learnt from his own occult godfather, who had earned his riches from drug dealers, discovering he could profit from the foolishness of others. He dedicated himself to spirits associated with criminals and criminal activity, and began offering drug cartels, spells of protection from rivals and law enforcement.
孔斯坦佐最终搬到了墨西哥城，在那里他从事模特工作，同时通过塔罗牌占卜来维持生计。他聚集了来自各行各业的追随者，其中几人成为了他的情人。在他二十出头的时候，孔斯坦佐把自己确立为一个强大的教父，为运气不佳的人施法。他的客户包括医生、政治家、模特、电影明星和警察。他的法术通常需要动物祭祀，从公鸡、山羊和蛇到斑马和狮子幼崽。后者花费了他超过 3,000 美元。他甚至袭击了一个墓地以获取用于他的魔药中的人类骨骼。孔斯坦佐从他自己的神秘教父那里学到了东西，后者从毒贩那里赚取了财富，并发现他可以从别人的愚蠢中获利。他把自己奉献给与罪犯和犯罪活动有关的灵魂，并开始向贩毒集团提供免受竞争对手和执法部门侵害的保护法术。
This earned him large amounts of money and clout. In 1987, he approached one of his biggest clients, requesting to become a full business partner with a 50% cut of sales. When his request was denied, the cartel leader and six of his family members and associates were found floating in the Rio de Zampango Canal with multiple body parts missing, including toes, ears, parts, testicles, brains and in one case, a spine. In July 1987, Constanzo met a college student named Sarah Aldrete, who had romantic links to drug dealers, and soon indoctrinated the 22-year-old into his religious practices. Aldrete's classmates noticed a dramatic shift in her personality, as the otherwise polite, straight A student had seemingly become an expert on witchcraft and black magic overnight. She started wearing black clothing and preaching the powers of darkness and light. At her parents' house in Matamoros, she decorated her bedroom with a cult paraphernalia, including an altar she prayed before every night. Constanzo made Aldrete a high priestess and his second in command, the godmother of his cult, and in November that year, she put him in touch with the Hernandez family.
这为他带来了巨额财富和影响力。1987年，他找到他最大的客户之一，要求成为全权合伙人并获得50%的销售分成。当他的请求遭到拒绝后，人们发现该贩毒集团首脑及其六名家属和同伙漂浮在赞潘戈河运河上，多处身体部位缺失，包括脚趾、耳朵、部分身体、睾丸、大脑，其中一人的脊椎也不翼而飞。1987年7月，孔斯坦佐结识了一名叫莎拉·阿尔德雷特的大学生，她与毒贩有浪漫关系，并很快将这个22岁的女孩洗脑，纳入其宗教实践中。阿尔德雷特的同学们注意到她的性格发生了戏剧性的转变，这个原本礼貌、门门拿A的学生一夜之间似乎成了巫术和黑魔法专家。她开始穿黑衣，宣扬光明与黑暗的力量。在马塔莫罗斯的父母家中，她用邪教用具装饰卧室，其中包括一个她每天晚上都要顶礼膜拜的祭坛。孔斯坦佐将阿尔德雷特封为最高女祭司和他的副手、其邪教的教母。同年11月，她将他引见给埃尔南德斯家族。
The Hernandez family turned to Constanzo following the murder of their ringleader, Saúl Hernandez Rivera, who had been gunned down presumably by rival drug dealers. Constanzo told the family that dedicating themselves to Palo Mayombe would grow their business, eliminate their enemies and make them invincible to law enforcement. In exchange, he required 50% of their profits and co-ownership of the business. They agreed, and in early 1989, Elio, Seraphine and several others were initiated into Constanzo's cult, undergoing rituals involving animal sacrifice. Business increased, strengthening their belief in the practice. Constanzo moved his headquarters to Rancho Santa Elena, where the rituals escalated to include human sacrifices. Constanzo told his flock that mutilation and pain were essential to Palo Mayombe and that the spirits he worshipped would be further appeased if their sacrifice died in agony. He then introduced Sodomy to their list of torches.
埃尔南德斯家族在他们的头目索尔·埃尔南德斯·里韦拉被谋杀后转向孔斯坦佐求助，索尔据信是被敌对毒贩枪杀的。孔斯坦佐告诉这个家族，投身帕洛马永贝邪教将发展他们的生意、消灭敌人，并使他们在执法部门面前立于不败之地。作为回报，他要求获得50%的利润并拥有该生意的共同所有权。他们同意了。1989年初，埃利奥、塞拉芬和另外几人加入了孔斯坦佐的邪教，接受了涉及动物献祭的仪式。生意蒸蒸日上，坚定了他们对这种习俗的信仰。孔斯坦佐将总部搬到了圣埃伦娜牧场，那里的仪式升级为包括活人献祭。孔斯坦佐告诉他的追随者，残肢断臂和痛苦对帕洛马永贝至关重要，如果献祭者在痛苦中死去，他所崇拜的神灵将得到进一步的抚慰。随后，他将鸡奸加入了他们的残害列表中。
Over a nine-month period, the cult killed mostly rival drug dealers and others who had crossed them. In one instance, they planned to sacrifice a former member, but he pulled out a gun and was promptly shot dead. Angered by this botched ritual, Elio ordered his men to abduct the first person they could find so the sacrifice could still go ahead. They brought him a boy with a burlap sack over his head, and Elio hastily decapitated him, only to discover that it was his 14-year-old cousin. In February 1989, Constanzo stole 800 kilograms of marijuana from a rival gang. To ensure its safe shipment across the Rio Grande, he ordered another human sacrifice. On Monday, March 13, a drug dealer was taken to Rancho Santa Helena, with each cult member taking turns cutting and kicking him, but their captive didn't make a sound during the attack. The silence irritated Constanzo as he believed suffering and pain were essential to gain power from the ritual, so he started skinning the man alive.
在九个月的时间里，该邪教杀害的人主要是敌对毒贩以及其他得罪过他们的人。有一次，他们计划献祭一名老成员，但对方掏出一把枪，当场被枪杀。埃利奥对这个搞砸的仪式感到愤怒，命令手下绑架他们能找到的第一个人，以便献祭能够继续进行。他们带来了一个头上套着麻袋的男孩，埃利奥仓促地将他斩首，却发现那是他14岁的表弟。1989年2月，孔斯坦佐从一个敌对帮派那里偷了800公斤大麻。为了确保其通过格兰德河安全运送，他下令进行另一次活人献祭。3月13日星期一，一名毒贩被带到圣埃伦娜牧场，每个邪教成员轮流对其进行刀砍和踢打，但他们的俘虏在袭击过程中没有发出一点声音。这种沉默激怒了孔斯坦佐，因为他认为苦难和痛苦对于从仪式中获得力量至关重要，于是他开始活剥这个男人的皮。
When he still refused to scream, Constanzo executed him with a machete, deeming the sacrifice worthless. He demanded his followers bring him another victim, someone with a good brain that he could feed to the spirits that lived inside his engaga to make them smarter. He told his followers, bring me someone I can use, someone who will scream. At around 1.30 am on March 14, Seraphine and another cult member drove into Matamoros and reached the main strip of Avenida Alvaro Obregon, where they spotted Mark Kilroy outside of Garcia's. They pulled up alongside him and asked if he needed a ride. Mark admitted he was drunk and requested a lift to Brownsville to meet up with his friends. Seraphine agreed and Mark climbed into the pickup. As they approached the Gateway International Bridge, Seraphine made a right turn onto a bumpy road framed by a high dirt levee that ran parallel with the Rio Grande.
当他依然拒绝尖叫时，孔斯坦佐用一把大砍刀处决了他，认为这次献祭毫无价值。他要求追随者给他带另一个受害者，一个拥有好大脑的人，他可以把这个大脑喂给栖息在他恩甘加内部的灵魂，使它们变得更聪明。他告诉追随者：“给我带一个我可以用的人，一个会尖叫的人。”3月14日凌晨1点30分左右，塞拉芬和另一名邪教成员开车进入马塔莫罗斯，到达阿尔瓦罗·奥夫雷贡大道的商业主街，他们在加西亚酒吧外面发现了马克·基尔罗伊。他们把车停在他旁边，问他是否需要搭便车。马克承认自己喝醉了，并请求搭车去布朗斯维尔与朋友会合。塞拉芬同意了，马克爬上了皮卡车。当他们接近网关国际大桥时，塞拉芬在一个颠簸的路口右转，这条路周围是一条与格兰德河平行的崇高土质堤坝。
He stopped the car in a parking lot and Mark was left alone as his two companions got out to urinate. Realizing something wasn't right, Mark scrambled out of the truck and took off in the direction of the border, even though the levee made it impossible to cross. As he ran, David, Serna, Valdez and Sergio Martinez-Selinas arrived, following behind in the blue Chevrolet suburban. They chased Mark down and ordered him to freeze, telling him he was under arrest for public intoxication. Mark stopped and was bound and blindfolded with duct tape, then forced into the back of the Chevy. By the time the group returned to the ranch, it was almost 3am. Seraphine gave Mark some crackers and water, reassuring him that nothing was going to happen. He then phoned his godmother, Sara Aldrete, telling her,
他把车停在一个停车场里，马克独自留在车里，因为他的两个同伴下车去小便了。马克意识到情况不对，从卡车里挣扎着爬出来，朝着边境方向逃跑，尽管堤坝使得越境成为不可能。当他逃跑时，大卫、塞尔纳、巴尔德斯和塞尔吉奥·马丁内斯-塞利纳斯乘坐一辆蓝色雪佛兰萨博班紧随其后赶到。他们追上马克，命令他站住，告诉他因醉酒闹事而被捕。马克停了下来，被胶带捆住双眼并蒙上眼睛，随后被强行塞进雪佛兰的后座。当这伙人回到牧场时，已经快凌晨3点了。塞拉芬给了马克一些饼干和水，安慰他说什么都不会发生。然后他打电话给他的教母萨拉·阿尔德雷特，告诉她：
We've done what he asked for. Early the next morning, Mark was removed from the truck and placed in a hammock between two trees. By midday, eight more cult members had arrived to participate in the sacrificial ceremony, including Constanzo, Elio and Aldrete. Constanzo believed women were bad luck for worship, and as the other men would be naked during the ritual, Aldrete was required to stay outside. Mark was taken into the wooden shack where he was forced to kneel before Constanzo and endure extreme acts of torture and sexual assault. Seraphine claimed he was outside when he heard a heavy thudding sound akin to the slicing of a coconut. He was then ordered to go inside the shack and, quote, take him out. Upon entering, he saw Mark Kilroy's naked body alongside a bloody machete, his head cracked open.
“我们已经完成了他要求的事。”第二天一早，马克被从卡车上抬下来，放在两棵树之间的吊床里。到了中午，又有八名邪教成员抵达以参加献祭仪式，其中包括孔斯坦佐、埃利奥和阿尔德雷特。孔斯坦佐认为女性对崇拜不利，而且由于其他男性在仪式期间将赤身裸体，阿尔德雷特被要求留在外面。马克被带进木屋，被迫在孔斯坦佐面前跪下，并遭受极端的酷刑和性侵犯。塞拉芬声称他在外面时听到了一声沉闷的撞击声，类似于切开椰子的声音。随后他被命令进入木屋，并被“带他出来”。进去后，他看到马克·基尔罗伊赤裸的尸体旁放着一把血迹斑斑的砍刀，他的头部裂开。
Seraphine could see his brain had been removed and placed inside the Anganga. He alleged Constanzo was the one who carried out the murder. Another member cut out Mark's heart, holding it up and declaring, My soul is dead, I am not a human being. Constanzo ordered Mark's legs to be cut off and he was buried in a shallow, one-metre deep grave. On Saturday, April 15, Mark Kilroy was farewell at his family's church, Our Lady of Lords. His younger brother, Keith, told the crowd of one thousand mourners. Mark loved life, he loved society, he was very trusting.
塞拉芬看到他的大脑已被取出并放入恩甘加内。他声称孔斯坦佐是行凶者。另一名成员割下了马克的Животное/心脏，把它高高举起并宣布：“我的灵魂已死，我不是人。”孔斯坦佐下令砍掉马克的双腿，并将他埋在一个深一米浅墓中。4月15日星期六，马克·基尔罗伊在他的家族教堂“我们的洛兹夫人教堂”举行了告别仪式。他年幼的弟弟基思对一千名哀悼者说：“马克热爱生活，他热爱社会，他非常信任他人。”
And that same society that he loved so much has taken him away from us. And because of them, we have to spend the rest of our lives without him. Reverend John the Fork declared Mark's death was not in vain, quote. God allows us to see the ugliness, the depraved and the senseless killing, so we might open our minds and hearts to become an answer to these horrible problems in the world. The Kilroy family derived comfort knowing that Mark had time to pray before his death, which had ultimately put a stop to the senseless killings. A family friend later told producers of the documentary Deadly Colts,
“而他如此深爱的那个社会却把他从我们身边夺走了。正因为他们，我们必须在没有他的陪伴下度过余生。”约翰·福克牧师宣告马克的死并非白白牺牲，原话是：“上帝让我们看到丑陋、堕落和无意义的杀戮，这样我们才能敞开心扉和心灵，成为解决世界上这些可怕问题的答案。”基尔罗伊家族从马克在死前有时间祈祷这一事实中得到了安慰，这最终制止了这场无意义的杀戮。一位家庭朋友后来告诉纪录片《致命小马》的制作人：
They honestly really, really felt like everything happened for a reason, that this was genuinely God's plan. This happened to Mark because without them finding Mark, who knows how long it would have taken to find all the other bodies. Mark was the instrument to show the evil of what this cult can do. Mark was laid to rest in the Mount Olivet Catholic Cemetery in Dickinson, Texas, with his headstone reading. We are proud of Mark and we thank God for the way Mark was and the way we were when with him. Mark is with God.
“他们真的、真的诚心觉得一切发生都是有原因的，这确实是上帝的计划。这件事降临到马克头上，是因为如果不找到马克，谁知道要花多久才能找到所有其他尸体。马克是展示这个邪教所能造成的邪恶的工具。”马克长眠于德克萨斯州迪金森的奥利维特山天主教公墓，他的墓碑上写着：“我们为马克感到骄傲，我们感谢上帝赋予马克的方式，以及我们与他在一起时的样子。马克与上帝同在。”
Do not be sad for Mark, be sad for yourselves and us, because another good man is missing from our world. He was a best friend to all. The families of other victims were left equally broken. Although many suspected their loved ones had met with foul play when they vanished, it took the disappearance of an American tourist before the case received police and media attention. Despite this, the parents of the youngest victim, 14-year-old Jose Luis Garcia Luna, harbored no resentment. Jose's mother told a reporter for the Brownsville Herald,
不要为马克悲伤，为你们自己和我们悲伤，因为我们的世界又少了一个好人。他是所有人的挚友。其他受害者的家庭同样心碎。尽管许多人在亲人失踪时怀疑他们遭遇了不测，但直到一名美国游客失踪，这个案件才引起了警方和媒体的关注。尽管如此，最年轻的受害者、14岁的何塞·路易斯·加西亚·卢纳的父母却没有怀恨在心。何塞的母亲告诉《布朗斯维尔先驱报》的一名记者：
If it weren't for the Kilroy boy, none of the other men, including my son, would ever have been found. Meanwhile, an international manhunt was underway for those responsible for the killings, with reported sightings coming from as far away as Chicago. A radio broadcast warned that Sarah Aldrete had been spotted near a school in southern Texas and had promised to kidnap and murder 10 children for every cult member that was captured. Fearful parents kept their children home from school until the threat was determined to have arisen from a prank phone call. As the cult had operations on both sides of the border, it was difficult to determine where exactly the fugitives were heading. Although records showed Constanzo and his crew had flown from Texas to Mexico City following the initial arrests,
“要不是基尔罗伊家的男孩，包括我儿子在内的其他所有人永远都不会被找到。”与此同时，一场针对杀戮真凶的国际大搜捕正在进行中，据报告目击线索远至芝加哥。一则无线电广播警告说，莎拉·阿尔德雷特在德克萨斯州南部的一所学校附近被目击，并承诺每抓到一个邪教成员就绑架并谋杀10个孩子。害怕的家长们把孩子留在家中不去上学，直到该威胁被确认为恶作剧电话。由于该邪教在边境两侧都有活动，很难确定逃犯究竟在前往何处。尽管记录显示孔斯坦佐和他的手下在最初逮捕后从德克萨斯州飞往墨西哥城，
authorities believed the leader was ultimately heading for his hometown of Miami, or perhaps to Houston, where he had links to a $20 million cocaine operation that had been busted the year prior. This speculation was leaked to the press and printed in newspapers, raising concerns that would cause the fugitives to change their plans. The homes of all members were searched and in Sarah Aldrete's bedroom, police found an altar covered in black candles with blood spattered across the wall. Using information provided by Elio, the police were able to pinpoint two apartments in Mexico City that were owned by Constanzo. The first was in Addis Aben de Saragosa, a municipality located 15 miles out of the city. It contained expensive electronics, furniture, clothing, and two clean altars. Two journals found in a desk drawer detailed the prices of Constanzo's spells, along with other indecipherable symbols.
当局认为该头目最终正前往他的家乡迈阿密，或者可能前往休斯敦，在那里他与一个去年被破获的2000万美元可卡因行动有联系。这一猜测被泄露给媒体并登上了报纸，引发了人们对这会促使逃犯改变计划的担忧。所有成员的住宅都遭到搜查，在莎拉·阿尔德雷特的卧室里，警察发现了一个摆满黑蜡烛的祭坛，墙上溅满了血迹。利用埃利奥提供的信息，警方得以精确定位孔斯坦佐在墨西哥城拥有的两处公寓。第一处位于阿迪斯·阿本德·萨拉戈萨，一个距离市区15英里外的直辖市。里面有昂贵的电子产品、家具、衣物和两个干净的祭坛。书桌抽屉里发现的两本日志详细记录了孔斯坦佐的法术价格，以及其他无法辨认的符号。
The second apartment was in the affluent Mexico City neighborhood of Colonia, Roma. A room at the rear of the property contained an altar similar to the one at Rancho Santa Elena. Cigars, peppers, and liquor bottles were strewn across the floor, and the room reaped of death, with bowls containing the remains of chickens, goats, and turtles. A purse and other items belonging to Sarah Aldrete were also found, leading some to speculate whether Constanzo had murdered her prior to fleeing. Others believed these items were intentionally left behind to throw investigators off track. Police also found a clothing receipt addressed to another of the wanted cult members, Omar Orea. They went to the address listed on the slip, a tall building of luxury condos in Colonia, Roma, arriving to Orea's apartment on the 10th floor. Inside, they caught a young woman packing a suitcase.
第二处公寓位于墨西哥城富裕的科洛尼亚罗马社区。房产后方的一个房间里有一个类似于圣埃伦娜牧场的祭坛。雪茄、辣椒和酒瓶散落一地，房间里弥漫着死亡的气息，碗里装着鸡、山羊和海龟的残骸。还发现了属于莎拉·阿尔德雷特的手提包和其他物品，这让一些人猜测孔斯坦佐是否在逃跑前谋杀了她。另一些人则认为这些物品是故意留下以误导调查人员的。警方还发现了一张写给另一名通缉邪教成员奥马尔·奥雷亚的服装收据。他们来到了纸条上列出的地址，那是科洛尼亚罗马的一栋高层豪华公寓楼，到达奥雷亚位于10楼的公寓时，他们在里面抓到一个正在收拾行李的年轻女子。
She introduced herself as the sister of one of the fugitives, saying that Constanzo and his followers were heading to Miami. But investigators were skeptical that this was a ruse to divert their attention. A shaman advised the Mexican federal police that destroying Constanzo's anganga would take away his power and likely lure him out of hiding. On Sunday, April 23, a cleansing ritual was carried out at the wooden shack at Rancho Santa Elena, where a pitcher of Constanzo was placed inside the anganga. Bags of salt were sprinkled on the floor, and gasoline was splashed on the walls. An agent lit a torch and threw it inside, engulfing the shack in flames. As the fire took hold, agents tossed salt into the air to drive away the evil spirits. Once the shack was reduced to ash, police placed a large wooden cross to mark the spot where it once stood.
她自我介绍说是其中一名逃犯的妹妹，并称孔斯坦佐和他的追随者正前往迈阿密。但调查人员怀疑这只是转移他们视线的诡计。一位萨满建议墨西哥联邦警察，摧毁孔斯坦佐的恩甘加将夺走他的力量，并很可能引诱他走出藏身之处。4月23日星期日，在圣埃伦娜牧场的木屋里举行了一场净化仪式，一个装有孔斯坦佐照片的投手被放进恩甘加里。几袋盐被洒在地板上，汽油泼在墙上。一名特工点燃火把扔了进去，木屋顿时被烈火吞噬。随着大火蔓延，特工们将盐撒向空中以驱赶恶灵。一旦木屋化为灰烬，警方就竖起了一个巨大的木十字架，以标记它曾经耸立的地方。
Photographs and video footage of the ritual were published in newspapers and televised on news programs across the United States and Mexico. After consulting local witchcraft practitioners and sorcerers, the police concluded Constanzo was likely hiding in the cosmopolitan Mexico City neighborhood of Colonia Cuauhtemoc. Locals were questioned, with one reporting seeing a woman in the area matching Cerro Aldrete's description. Police then witnessed a man with pink dyed hair at a supermarket trying to buy a large amount of groceries using a US $100 bill. They followed him to an apartment building on Rio Center and kept the area under surveillance for a week, believing the man was wanted cult member Alvaro De Leon Valdez and that he was purchasing groceries for Constanzo. At around 2pm on Saturday, May 6, four plainclothes detectives pulled up to the apartment where they noticed an abandoned vehicle parked outside. As they approached to examine it, they were suddenly peppered with bullets. They took cover and called for backup as a man wielding an Uzi submachine gun shot at them from the window of the adjacent apartment building.
该仪式的照片和视频片段发表在报纸上，并在美国和墨西哥的新闻节目中播出。在咨询了当地的巫术从业者和巫师后，警方得出结论，孔斯坦佐很可能藏匿在墨西哥城充满大都市气息的科洛尼亚库奥特莫克社区。当地人受到了盘问，其中一人报告说在该地区看到了一名符合塞罗·阿尔德雷特描述的女性。随后，警察在一家超市目击了一个染着粉红色头发的男子，他试图用一张100美元的美国钞票购买大量杂货。他们跟踪他到里约中心的一栋公寓楼，并在该地区进行了为期一周的监视，认为该男子是通缉中的邪教成员阿尔瓦罗·德莱昂·瓦尔德斯，并且他正在为孔斯坦佐购买杂货。5月6日星期六下午2点左右，四名便衣侦探将车开到公寓旁，注意到外面停着一辆被弃置的车辆。当他们走近去检查时，突然遭到密集的子弹袭击。他们寻找掩护并请求增援，与此同时，一名手持乌兹冲锋枪的男子从相邻公寓楼的窗户向他们开枪。
Bullets shattered shop windows and cracked the sidewalk as the man screamed at the police. He started throwing American $20 and $50 bills and gold coins to the street below, yelling. This is for you, you poor animals. Some officers and bystanders rushed to grab the money, only to scatter as they were shot at. 180 police officers and federal agents descended on the scene, establishing barricades and roadblocks while clearing the area of civilians. After an hour, Sarah Aldrete ran out of the building, followed closely by another of the fugitives, Alvaro De Leon Valdez. Aldrete shouted, don't shoot, don't shoot, I'm coming out, I've escaped and told police that Constanzo was inside the apartment and had ended his own life. Suspecting Aldrete's surrender was a ploy, police cautiously entered the apartment, where they found Omar O'Rea hiding under a bed.
子弹击碎了商店的窗户，砸裂了人行道，男子向警察大喊大叫。他开始向下面的街道抛撒20美元和50美元的美国钞票以及金币，大喊：“这是给你们的，你们这些可怜的动物。”一些警察和旁观者冲过去抢钱，但在遭到枪击后四散奔逃。180名警察和联邦特工赶到现场，建立路障和封锁线，同时清理该区域的平民。一个小时后，莎拉·阿尔德雷特从大楼里跑了出来，紧随其后的是另一名逃犯阿尔瓦罗·德莱昂·瓦尔德斯。阿尔德雷特大喊：“别开枪，别开枪，我出来了，我逃出来了”，并告诉警察孔斯坦佐在公寓里面并已经了结了自己的生命。怀疑阿尔德雷特的投降是个计谋，警察小心翼翼地进入公寓，发现奥马尔·奥雷亚正躲在一张床底下。
The bloody bodies of Constanzo and another cult member, Martin Quintana Rodriguez, lay side by side on the floor of the bedroom closet with fatal gunshot wounds. The three survivors revealed Constanzo, after noticing the police presence outside, began firing from the window. He had decided he would rather die than be arrested, believing he would be resurrected. He ordered Omar O'Rea to shoot him, the others, and then himself. When O'Rea expressed reluctance, Constanzo demanded, do it or I'll make things tough on you in hell. Alvaro De Leon Valdez carried out the killing instead, shooting Constanzo and Quintana, but the slaughter ended there. A cult paraphernalia was found throughout the apartment, including two swords, black candles, a wax skull, and a blindfolded doll. $3000 in cash had been burned on the stovetop, allegedly destroyed by Constanzo during the gun battle, who told his followers, no one's going to have this money.
孔斯坦佐和另一名邪教成员马丁·昆塔纳·罗德里格斯的血淋淋的尸体并排躺在卧室衣柜的地板上，身上有致命的枪伤。三个幸存者透露，孔斯坦佐在注意到外面有警察后，开始从窗户开枪。他决定宁可死也不愿被捕，因为他相信自己会复活。他命令奥马尔·奥雷亚枪杀他、其他人以及他自己。当奥雷亚表现出不情愿时，孔斯坦佐要求：“动手，否则我在地狱里对你不客气。”阿尔瓦罗·德莱昂·瓦尔德斯代替他完成了杀戮，枪杀了孔斯坦佐和昆塔纳，但杀戮到此结束。公寓各处都发现了邪教用具，包括两把剑、黑蜡烛、一个蜡头骨和一个被蒙住双眼的娃娃。灶台上烧毁了3000美元现金，据称是孔斯坦佐在枪战期间销毁的，他告诉追随者：“谁也别想得到这笔钱。”
After the group initially fled from Texas following the raid on Rancho Santa Elena, they disguised themselves by dyeing their hair and wearing sunglasses and hats, and kept a low profile in the outskirts of Mexico City. When Constanzo saw the news footage of his engarga being destroyed, he screamed and fired his machine gun at the television, fearful that his powers had been diminished. On April 25, the fugitives returned into Mexico City, moving between the apartments of their associates, before finally taking refuge in their final hideout in Colonia, Cuauhtemoc. Hours before the shootout on May 6, Sarah Audrette threw a handwritten note out the window, which read, Please call the judicial police and tell them that in this building are those they are seeking. Tell them that a woman is being held hostage. I beg for this, because what I want most is to talk, or they're going to kill the girl. The note was found by two young men walking on the street below. One looked up and made eye contact with Audrette, but he thought it was just a joke, and didn't hand the note to authorities until after the shootout. Sarah Audrette, Omar O'Rea and Alvaro de Leon Valdez were placed under arrest.
在圣埃伦娜牧场突袭后该团伙最初从德克萨斯州逃跑时，他们通过染发、戴太阳镜和帽子来伪装自己，并在墨西哥城郊区保持低调。当孔斯坦佐看到他的恩甘加被毁的新闻画面时，他尖叫并用机枪向电视开枪，担心自己的力量已经减弱。4月25日，逃犯们返回墨西哥城，在同伙的公寓之间流窜，最后躲进他们在科洛尼亚库奥特莫克的最终藏身处。在5月6日枪战发生前几小时，莎拉·奥德雷特从窗户扔下一张手写便条，上面写着：“请打电话给司法警察，告诉他们他们寻找的人在这栋大楼里。告诉他们一个女人被扣为人质。我恳求这么做，因为我最想做的是谈谈，否则他们会杀了那个女孩。”这张便条被两个在下面街道上走路的年轻人发现了。一个人抬头与奥德雷特对视了一眼，但他以为这只是个玩笑，直到枪战结束后才把便条交给当局。莎拉·奥德雷特、奥马尔·奥雷亚和阿尔瓦罗·德莱昂·瓦尔德斯被捕。
Audrette portrayed herself as a victim of the cult, claiming she had been taken hostage and forced to go along with the group's demands. She denied any involvement in the sacrificial rituals, saying she felt sorry for the Kilroy family, and revealing she had volunteered to help James Kilroy hand out his son's missing person posters. Yet, evidence indicated Audrette was a willing participant in the cult's activities. She was able to describe several of the murders in detail and failed to provide any proof that she had been abducted. Each of the seven arrested cult members faced different charges based on their involvement in the 15 murders, including those of cult members Constanzo and Martin Quintana Rodriguez. Some also faced charges for drug trafficking, criminal association and cover-up, as well as burial, narcotics and weapons violations. The trials commenced in July of 1989, but given the huge amount of paperwork the presiding judge had to examine, it took years to reach a conclusion. Omar O'Rea died from AIDS mid-trial in February 1990.
奥德雷特把自己描绘成邪教的受害者，声称她被劫为人质并被迫顺从该团伙的要求。她否认参与任何献祭仪式，称她对基尔罗伊家族感到同情，并透露她曾自愿帮助詹姆斯·基尔罗伊分发他儿子的寻人启事。然而，证据表明奥德雷特是邪教活动的自愿参与者。她能够详细描述几起谋杀案，却未能提供任何自己被绑架的证据。被捕的七名邪教成员每人都因参与15起谋杀案而面临不同的指控，其中包括邪教成员孔斯坦佐和马丁·昆塔纳·罗德里格斯的谋杀案。一些人还面临贩毒、犯罪结伙和窝藏罪名，以及埋葬、毒品和武器违规行为。审判于1989年7月开始，但鉴于主审法官必须审查的大量文件，耗费了数年时间才得出结论。奥马尔·奥雷亚在1990年2月审判中途死于艾滋病。
In August that same year, Alvaro de Leon Valdez was sentenced to 30 years in prison for the murders of Constanzo and Quintana. In May 1994, five years after the cult was uncovered, Sarah Audrette, Seraphine Hernandez Garcia, Elio Hernandez Rivera and the two men who captured Marc and drove him to the ranch. David Serna Valdez and Sergio Martinez Salinas were each sentenced to 67 years. A federal court later reduced their sentences to 50 years after the court ruled it was the maximum they should have received under Mexican law. If they are ever released from prison, American authorities plan to prosecute them for the murder of Marc Kilroy. Sarah Audrette quote I am sorry because of all the things that happened. I'm sorry because of all the killing. I don't know how I got into this without knowing what it was. Constanzo would order you to do something and you would do it, but I don't know why. He was like a leader or something. We were like followers.
同年8月，阿尔瓦罗·德莱昂·瓦尔德斯因谋杀孔斯坦佐和昆塔纳被判处30年监禁。1994年5月，即邪教被揭露五年后，莎拉·奥德雷特、塞拉芬·埃尔南德斯·加西亚、埃利奥·埃尔南德斯·里韦拉以及那两个俘虏了马克并开车把他带到牧场的两个男人——大卫·塞尔纳·瓦尔德斯和塞尔吉奥·马丁内斯·萨利纳斯——分别被判处67年监禁。联邦法院后来将他们的刑期减至50年，因为法院裁定这是他们在墨西哥法律下应受到的最高刑罚。如果他们有一天能出狱，美国当局计划起诉他们谋杀马克·基尔罗伊。莎拉·奥德雷特原话：“我对发生的所有事情感到抱歉。我对所有的杀戮感到抱歉。我不知道自己是怎么在不知情的情况下卷入其中的。孔斯坦佐会命令你做某事，你就会去做，但我不知道为什么。他就像个领导什么的。我们就像是追随者。”
As life sentences and the death penalty did not exist in the Mexican judicial system, the Kilroy family and US officials expressed satisfaction with the outcome. Helen Kilroy told reporters quote We were concerned that maybe they weren't going to get sentenced, that they were going to let things quiet down and be released, but I'm glad those fears were unfounded. I think we and the people of Mexico can feel safer. Brownsville Sheriff's Lieutenant George Gavito, who was the first law enforcement official to learn of Marc's disappearance, said I just really commend the Mexican government for doing it. I think it sends a message over here to us that justice was done over there. Three of the cult's victims were never identified, and Mexican authorities suspect Constanzo had ritualistically murdered another 16 children. A pair of children's shoes were uncovered at the ranch, and baby's belongings, including photographs, were found near the bloody altar in Sarah Eldrette's bedroom. There were also unsubstantiated reports that a small human skull was found in Constanzos and Gaga. Although the media followed the more sensationalist Satanism angle, the Kilroy family believed the real problem was drug-related violence in northern Mexico.
由于墨西哥司法系统中没有无期徒刑和死刑，基尔罗伊家族和美国官员对这一结果表示满意。海伦·基尔罗伊告诉记者：“我们曾担心他们可能不会被判刑，担心事情会平息下来然后他们就被释放了，但我很高兴这些担忧是没有根据的。我想我们和墨西哥人民都可以感到更安全了。”布朗斯维尔警长中尉乔治·加维托是第一个获悉马克失踪的执法官员，他表示：“我真的赞赏墨西哥政府这样做。我认为这向我们传递了一个信息，即正义在那里得到了伸张。”邪教的三名受害者从未被确认身份，墨西哥当局怀疑孔斯坦佐还仪式性地谋杀了另外16名儿童。在牧场发现了一双儿童鞋，在莎拉·埃尔德雷特的卧室血迹斑斑的祭坛附近发现了婴儿用品，包括照片。还有未经证实的报告称，在孔斯坦佐的恩甘加中发现了一个小人类头骨。尽管媒体关注更为耸人听闻的撒旦教角度，但基尔罗伊家族认为真正的问题是墨西哥北部的贩毒暴力。
In May 1989, they founded the Marc Kilroy Foundation, which provides drug education to young people. They met with then-president George Bush and made appearances on talk shows in churches and on the steps of Austin State Capitol to promote their cause. Helen Kilroy told The New York Times, We've stopped and wondered what we were doing several times, but I think we were meant to do this, because at every bad moment we hear from somebody, an addict, a parent that has lost a child, somebody who says they want us to keep going. In 2009, as the 20th anniversary of Marc's death approached, the Kilroy's visited Matamoros and the Rio Grande Valley to thank the locals who helped find their son. In December 2014, Helen Kilroy passed away at the age of 70. Her funeral was held in the same church where Marc had been farewelled 25 years earlier. She is buried alongside her son in a family plot, with memorial bricks featuring their names on permanent display outside the Santa Fe Independent School District Building.
1989年5月，他们创立了马克·基尔罗伊基金会，为年轻人提供毒品教育。他们会见了时任总统乔治·布什，并出现在脱口秀节目中、教堂里以及奥斯汀州议会大厦的台阶上，以宣传他们的事业。海伦·基尔罗伊告诉《纽约时报》：“我们曾多次停下来思考我们在做什么，但我想我们注定要这样做，因为在每一个糟糕的时刻，我们都会听到来自某个人——一个瘾君子、一个失去孩子的家长、一个说他们希望我们坚持下去的人的声音。”2009年，随着马克逝世20周年纪念日的临近，基尔罗伊一家访问了马塔莫罗斯和格兰德河谷，感谢那些帮助寻找他们儿子的当地人。2014年12月，海伦·基尔罗伊逝世，享年70岁。她的葬礼在25年前马克告别仪式的同一座教堂举行。她与儿子合葬在家族墓地中，刻有他们名字的纪念砖永久陈列在圣达菲独立学区大楼外。
As of 2019, the Marc Kilroy Foundation is still active. In April, the Foundation announced that it awarded $6,000 in scholarships to three graduating seniors. Rancho Santa Elena stood abandoned for years after the crimes came to light, slowly overrun by wildflowers and grass. A year after Marc Kilroy's death, local police reported that fresh holes appearing on the site had been dug by residents desperately seeking missing loved ones. The Mexican government eventually took ownership of the land and tried to turn it into a corn and sorghum farm, but were unable to find any staff willing to work there. Thank you for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
截至2019年，马克·基尔罗伊基金会依然活跃。4月份，基金会宣布向三名应届毕业生颁发了6,000美元的奖学金。罪行曝光后，圣埃伦娜牧场荒废多年，野花和杂草渐渐蔓延开来。马克·基尔罗伊死后一年，当地警方报告称，现场出现的新洞穴是急切寻找失踪亲人的居民挖的。墨西哥政府最终接管了这片土地，并试图将其变成玉米和大高粱农场，但找不到任何愿意在那里工作的员工。感谢观看。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。